- Thanks to Indochino for
keeping LegalEagle in the air
and helping me look fly.
If you were taking bets on
what President Trump would do
after being acquitted of
impeachment in the Senate,
and you said meddle in the affairs
of the Department of Justice
in a way that would make
Richard Nixon blush,
well, you win, yay!
As you probably know,
Attorney General Barr
has begun overtly inserting
himself into the DOJ cases
that directly affect the president.
That interference caused four prosecutors
at the DOJ to withdraw from
the case of Roger Stone,
and one resigned from the DOJ entirely.
This is not normal.
It's Nixon Saturday Night
Massacre if AG Richardson
and Deputy AG Rucklehaus
hadn't resigned in protest.
(somber music)
Hey, LegalEagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer
because with every passing day,
there are fewer and fewer good lawyers
at the Department of Justice.
On this episode of what
the crap is going on
with the Justice Department,
we're gonna take a look
at the current debacle
involving the DOJ,
President Trump, AG Barr
and Judge Amy Berman Jackson,
as it pertains to the sentencing
of former Trump campaign
advisor Roger Stone Jr
because the rule of law is at stake here.
It's hard to overestimate just how crazy
this whole situation is.
So how did we get here?
Well, last November, the self-proclaimed,
Machiavellian Richard-Nixon-loving
Roger Stone Jr
was convicted in federal
court on seven counts,
including one count of
obstruction of proceeding,
five counts of making false statements
and one count of witness tampering.
Seriously, someone needs to
explain to me how this guy
is not starring in the next Batman movie
as the supervillain Penguin.
He's definitely got the look.
On Monday, February 10th, prosecutors
from the Department of Justice submitted
their recommendation for
Roger Stone's sentencing
after he had already been convicted
of seven different felonies.
Now often prosecutors will
offer a more lenient sentence
in exchange for a plea bargain
and not having to go through the trouble
of actually going through the trial.
Roger Stone wanted to roll the dice
and went through the
entire trial which resulted
in his convictions.
As a result, the Department of
Justice requested a sentence
within the Federal Sentencing Guidelines
of between seven and nine years.
But what happened next can
only be described as bananas
because apparently, upon
seeing the recommended sentence
by the DOJ, the president violated a norm
that says that a president
should not comment
on ongoing criminal prosecutions
and fired off the tweet saying,
"This is a horrible and
very unfair situation.
"The real crimes were on the other side
"as nothing happens to them.
"Cannot allow this
miscarriage of justice."
In less than 24 hours
after the initial
sentencing recommendation
and the subsequent Trump tweet,
the four line prosecutors
of the DOJ who are handling
the Stone case withdrew
from the case and one actually resigned
from the Department of Justice
while new prosecutors handling this case
at the DOJ claim that they made a decision
prior to the Trump tweet,
they submitted a supplemental
amended sentencing memorandum
recommending a lighter sentence.
In doing so, they stated
that the initial sentencing recommendation
filed the day before, quote,
does not accurately reflect
the Department of Justice's position
on what would be a reasonable
sentence in this matter.
And I don't know if I can
adequately convey to you
how crazy this is or
what it must feel like
to be one of those DOJ prosecutors.
Imagine yourself, a respected
Department of Justice lawyer,
who just made a sentencing recommendation
to a federal judge, you're looking good
in your Indochino suit,
you spent at least a year
on this case, you took
it to trial and you won,
and the sentencing recommendation
was vetted by your boss
and your boss's boss,
and it was within the federal guidelines
yet just hours after you
file your recommendation
with the court, the big boss,
the political boss comes in
and says your months of work
on the case don't matter at all
and your recommendation is wrong.
And the President even weighs in
on how bad your original work product is.
You can imagine that these
prosecutors are pissed.
And initially people were wondering
if this was a political hatchet job,
and if Bill Barr or the
President was responsible for it.
And then the president tweeted to confirm
that it was both political
and that Bill Barr
was responsible for it.
The tweets from the president kept coming
applauding Attorney General Bill Barr
and condemning Judge Amy Berman Jackson
and the four person for the Stone trial.
All of this with the
actual sentencing date
imminently approaching and
Trump's constant tweets
about the matter undercut
the Department of Justice's position
that it made the decision
to reverse itself
on the sentencing recommendation
without any intervention
from President Trump.
So why is this such a big deal?
Well, the Department
of Justice and the FBI
are law enforcement agencies
that theoretically operate
outside of the political
influence from the White House.
Now of course, the President
appoints the Attorney General
and often the US Attorneys.
But in the American system of government,
the President is not empowered
to use the FBI and DOJ
for political purposes,
or to save his cronies
from punishment.
The controversy over the Stone sentencing
is the latest in a series of events
that is potentially
eroding the independence
of the Department of Justice
and coloring their actions
with a political pen.
So before we get into
the sentencing fiasco,
here's a quick primer on Roger Stone
and the charges and conviction
that led to the current implosion going on
at the DOJ right now.
Now Roger Stone, as you may know,
is a Republican advisor
that has been around
since the campaign days of Richard Nixon.
He's played roles in several campaigns,
some successful, hola Ronald Reagan,
and some not so much like Bob Dole.
Stone is, to put it mildly, a character.
Stone once told The New Yorker,
"It's rare that I'm accused of something
"that I'm not guilty of."
The self described dirty trickster
was most recently a former
adviser to President Trump.
Last year, Stone was arrested on charges
of obstruction of justice,
giving false statements
and witness tampering that all stemmed
from findings of Special
Counsel Robert Muller's probe
into the Russian election interference.
Specifically, these charges
related to his efforts
to provide the Trump campaign
with inside information
from WikiLeaks about hacked emails,
and his subsequent lying about it
to the House Intelligence Committee.
During Stone's trial, the DOJ
showed that the Trump campaign
was told in April of 2016
that Wikileaks had the ability
to hack email accounts of Hillary Clinton,
her campaign chair John Podesta, the DOC
and other government email accounts,
and it was subsequently confirmed
that Stone was interacting
and negotiating with Wikileaks
head honcho Julian Assange.
Stone spoke with senior
Trump campaign officials
about Wikileaks and quote,
information it might have had
that would be damaging
to the Clinton campaign
and senior campaign
officials later asked Stone
about any future releases from WikiLeaks.
Various statements by Stone,
including many public ones
raised questions about whether he had
some sort of inside knowledge
about WikiLeaks or its plans.
He denied having any such
knowledge and claimed
that anything that he
did know about Wikileaks
came through an intermediary,
radio host Randy Credico,
although it was ultimately
proven that the information
was coming from conservative author
and conspiracy theorist, Jerome Corsi.
Ultimately, the charges and conviction
focused on Stone's alleged lies
to the House Intelligence
Committee during 2017
about his efforts to get
in touch with Wikileaks
during the campaign.
In addition, Stone was convicted of trying
to tamper and intimidate
a witness, Credico
to ensure that he would either
stick to a false narrative
or plead The Fifth.
In fact, at one point Stone suggested
that those testifying regarding
the WikiLeaks information
should pull a Frank Pentangeli
to prevent contradicting
Stone's earlier testimony,
which relates to "The Godfather,"
because of course it does.
- I don't know no godfather.
- And Stone was no mere coffee boy.
During Stone's trial,
the government admitted
for the first time that Stone
may have discussed Wikileaks
with Donald Trump during
the summer of 2016.
In fact, Rick gates testified
that he was in a limousine with Trump
on their way to LaGuardia Airport
when Trump talked on the phone with Stone
about the hacked emails.
This information was apparently redacted
from the Mueller report
and was not made public
until the Stone trial.
it directly contradicts Trump's
statement to Robert Mueller
that, quote, I do not
recall discussing Wikileaks
with Stone nor do I recall
being aware of Mr. Stone
having discussed Wikileaks
with individuals associated
with my campaign.
So we can assume that Stone
has a lot of information
about President Trump that the President
may not want to become public,
leading some to speculate that regardless
of what sentence is handed down to Stone,
he will avoid substantial jail time,
specifically because he knows
so much damaging information
about President Trump, likely
through a presidential pardon.
So Roger Stone was
convicted of all charges
on November 15th, 2019,
leading to the crucial sentencing phase
that we're in right now.
As with other cases,
prior to the pending sentencing hearing,
the prosecutors for the DOJ
prepared a memorandum giving
their sentencing
recommendation to the judge.
Government prosecutors base
their sentencing recommendations
on the United States Sentencing Guidelines
for the offenses of conviction.
In the recommendation,
the prosecutors explain
the reasoning for the government's
sentencing suggestion.
Prosecutors took a hard line on Stone
because in addition to lying under oath,
obstructing Congress's investigation
into Russian interference
in the 2016 election,
and witness tampering, Stone
showed a total contempt
for the court and the legal system.
The original sentencing memorandum states,
"But when his crimes were
revealed by the indictment
"in his case, he didn't
splayed contempt for this Court
"and the rule of law.
"For that, he should be punished in accord
"with the advisory Guidelines."
The memorandum highlights the facts
that were fleshed out in Stone's trial,
including the Trump's campaign team
believe that Stone was providing them
with nonpublic information
about Wikileaks' plans.
And with reference to the testimony
before the House Intelligence Committee,
the memorandum states that Stone told
the committee five categories of lies.
Those lies were designed to
conceal Stone's communications
with Corsi, Credico and the Trump campaign
about Wikileaks in 2016.
And a crucial factor for the
sentencing recommendation
and perhaps the straw
that broke the DOJ's back
was that the crimes committed
by Stone involved violence
or the threat of violence.
The sentencing memorandum
highlights a few key instances
where this was evident.
For instance, on April 9th, 2018
an email chain about Stone's testimony,
Stone wrote to his alleged
intermediary, Credico,
quote, I'm going to take
that dog away from you.
Not a (bleep) thing you
can do about it either
because you are a weak
broke piece of (bleep).
Stone also told me Credico
to, quote, prepare to die.
- Prepare to die.
- Although Credico
stated he didn't believe
that Stone would steal his
dog or hurt him directly,
he did state that he was worried
about other people getting
ideas if Stone posted
the message directly,
which is the idea behind
stochastic terrorism.
Now all of these facts resulted
in a guideline recommended
sentence of seven to nine years.
And it's true the
prosecutors have discretion
for proposed sentences.
But government prosecutors
don't make arbitrary
sentencing recommendations.
They're required to use the
Federal Sentencing Guidelines,
which themselves were a response
to wildly different
sentences being handed down
by federal judges, often
based on race rather
than criminal severity.
So the Federal Sentencing Guidelines
are a non-binding set
of rules that set out
a uniform sentencing policy
for defendants convicted
in the federal court system.
Judges can disregard those
sentencing guidelines,
but often they're seen as
prima facie reasonable.
A defendant's sentence is determined
by many different factors
ranging from his subjective guilt
to how harmful his actions
were to the actors involved.
Without getting too bogged
down in the details,
when you're using the
sentencing guidelines,
you first create a base
level which is predetermined
based on the actual convictions,
then that level can either be increased
or decrease due to specific
offense characteristics.
Here the original DOJ
sentencing memorandum
increased Stone's base level based in part
on the threats of
violence that were issued.
The memorandum stated that pursuant
to the sentencing guidelines,
eight levels should be added
because the offense
quote, involves causing
or threatening to cause physical injury
to a person or property damage
in order to obstruct the
administration of justice.
In supporting their position,
the memorandum noted the standard applied
in previous federal cases, for example,
in US versus Plumley, the
court held that quote,
to apply the enhancement,
there is no additional
seriousness requirement
beyond the fact of a violent threat,
and thus with the crimes
that Stone was convicted of
and the threat of violence
used in the commission
of those crimes, the Justice Department
came to a recommendation
of seven to nine years
and although the president
and his advocates
think that the sentencing
recommendation is excessive,
it's in line with how
the DOJ views threats
and witness tampering.
Stone's crimes are exactly
the kind of offenses
that strike at the heart
of the justice system,
blocking investigations, lying under oath
and threatening witnesses
are all mob like tactics
meant to subvert justice
rather than advance the truth.
And when it comes to threatening
witnesses with violence,
DOJ usually recommends harsher sentences
regardless of whether the victim feels
like the threat is credible or not,
especially under circumstances
where the defendant
doesn't want to plead out
for a lighter sentence
and forces the government
to go through the trial.
And as many advocates of
criminal justice reform
have pointed out, federal
sentences can be very harsh,
sometimes draconian, and it would be great
if there was across the board reform
to maybe tweak some of those sentences
and maybe ratchet down some
of the sentencing guidelines.
It just seems really
bad when the only people
who get that kind of
reduction in sentences
are friends of the President.
So back to the story at hand,
one day and one Presidential tweet later
an amended and supplemental memorandum
was shockingly submitted
by the Justice Department.
This just doesn't happen.
The new memorandum makes
only a passing mention
to the government's previous
recommendation in the case,
which was filed less
than 24 hours earlier.
The new filing only says
that its prior sentence
recommendation, quote,
does not accurately reflect
the Department of Justice's position
on what would be a reasonable
sentence in this matter.
In the new amended memorandum,
the government declined to
make a specific recommendation
beyond saying that
incarceration was appropriate.
The sentencing length, the new MO reads
should be left to the judges discretion.
The government defers to the court
as to what specific
sentence is appropriate
under the facts and
circumstances of this case.
The filing was signed by John Crabb, Jr,
the Acting Chief of the Criminal Division
in the DC-US Attorney's office
who entered in his appearance
in the case minutes
before the memo was filed.
In justifying the DOJ
his newfound position,
the memorandum states that although Stone
allegedly had threatened
witness Credico's therapy dog,
Bianca, saying that he was, quote,
going to take that dog away from you,
it was important to
recognize that Credico,
a New York radio host has
acknowledged that he quote,
never in any way felt
that Stone himself posed
a direct physical threat to me or my dog.
Essentially what this comes down to
is that the revised memorandum argues
that there was never really any
threat of physical violence.
As a result, the previous memorandum
is supposedly misguided, and, quote,
if the court were not to apply
the eight level enhancement
for threatening a witness
with physical injury,
it would result in the defendant receiving
an advisory guideline
range of 37 to 46 months,
which is more in line with
the typical sentences imposed
in obstruction cases, end quote.
It goes on to urge the judge
to consider Stone's advanced age, health,
personal circumstances and
lack of criminal history
in fashioning an appropriate sentence.
And it's true that both
sentencing recommendations
could, in fact, be reasonable.
The DOJ did not have to move
for the enhancement based
on the witness threatening
but by the same token,
it was totally reasonable
for them to move forward
with that enhancement
based on threatening.
The fact that reasonable minds
can disagree about the original
sentence highlights the fact
that it's probably political intervention,
seeking less harsh
sentence for a compatriot
of the President.
And the results speak for themselves
and highlight how unusual this was.
The revised memorandum led
to the shocking withdrawal
of four career US attorneys,
with one outright resigning from his job.
This led to backlash from within Congress,
especially from members of the
House Intelligence Committee,
who Stone lied to,
Representative Adam Schiff,
the California democrat
who was the lead prosecutor
in Trump's impeachment
trial said that quote,
if reports are correct,
the Department of Justice
and Attorney General bill Barr are poised
to overrule career prosecutors
who made a sentencing
recommendation yesterday,
following a midnight tweet
from the president attacking
the proposed length of the sentence.
Bar, of course, defends
his position and argued
it was, quote, preposterous
to characterize
his role in the Stone
sentencing recommendation
as an intervention.
He argued that he was simply attempting
to resolve an internal department dispute.
This, of course is poppycock because
any internal DOJ dispute
about the Stone sentencing
would have been settled before
the first memo was filed.
In other words, DOJ lawyers are supposed
to be consummate professionals.
Filing a memo on Monday and
backtracking 24 hours later
is amateur hour that you really don't see
from the Department of Justice.
And this is not the first time
that President Trump's
DOJ has pulled the rug out
from its own attorneys in
front of a federal judge.
If you recall, last year in the midst
of the battle over adding
a citizenship question
to the 2020 census, the Justice Department
tried to withdraw and
replace his legal team
with no explanation.
The DOJ filed motions
in two courts seeking
to remove its own lawyers from the cases.
Two federal judges
denied the DOJ's motions
and the inference was clear.
There was significant
turmoil amongst the attorneys
at the Justice Department
who didn't want to lie
to federal judges about whether they could
or could not include a citizenship
question in the census.
So now all of the attention is
on these four line prosecutors
who are career attorneys
for the government.
Even President Trump,
for that matter tweeted,
who are the four
prosecutors, Mueller people
who cut and ran after being exposed
for recommending a ridiculous
nine-year prison sentence
to a man that got caught
up in an investigation
that was illegal, the Mueller Scam
and shouldn't ever even have started?
13 angry democrats, question mark.
Well, let's answer that question.
These four people are a group
of Ivy-League-educated prosecutors
with some noteworthy bullet points
on their curriculum vitae.
Reports are that these four prosecutors
have no history of political contributions
in the last 10 years.
My contacts at the DOJ say
that all of these people
were extremely well liked
and hyper-competent.
So the situation at the
Department of Justice
can only be described as dire.
Career prosecutors are being overruled
by Attorney General Barr
with little to no explanation
and what appears to be
overtly political reasons
on the face of it.
The President of the United
States is attacking DOJ lawyers
during his nightly Twitter time
and judges are criticizing
the government's position
and now AG Barr has
admitted to bring in a team
of Midwestern lawyers to review
and reverse determinations
made by DOJ prosecutors
on national security cases
that may implicate the president.
As David Lockman,
a former senior Justice
Department official said,
the move was quote, a shocking,
cram-down political intervention
in the criminal justice process.
We are now truly at a
break-glass-in-case-of-fire moment
for the Justice Department.
Of course, there are those
on the President's defense
arguing that this is just a
plot by prosecutors linked
to the Mueller probe to
legitimize their, now defunct,
Russian election
interference investigation,
but with hints at a potential pardon
in congratulatory tweets
coming from the president,
stating congratulations to
Attorney General Bill Barr
for taking charge of a case
that was totally out of control
and perhaps should not
have even been brought.
Evidence now clearly shows
that the Mueller Scam
was improperly brought and tainted.
Even Bob Mueller lied to Congress.
Even the President's own
allies and those close
to the situation are asking the president
to show a little restraint.
Attorney General Barr is going to testify
in front of Congress at the end of March
but he appeared on ABC
for an interview saying...
- I cannot do my job
here at the department
with a constant background
commentary that undercuts me.
To have public statements and tweets
made about the department,
about people in the department,
our men and women here about
cases pending in the department
and about judges before whom we have cases
make it impossible for me to do my job
and to assure the courts
and the prosecutors
in the department that we're
doing our work with integrity.
- Barr suggested that the
President wasn't involved
and that he made the decision on his own.
But that ignores the fact that
this action clearly benefits
the president and is
what the president wants.
So that really doesn't clear
the air in any meaningful way.
And some have lauded Bill Barr
for breaking with the president
and suggesting that the
Department of Justice
is independent, but based
on the President's reaction
or non-reaction, saying that Bill Barr
can do whatever he wants,
I think this is more likely
just political theater
as commentator Quint Jurassic
put it, this is kayfabe.
In other words, what they
do in professional wrestling
where they appear to have fights
when they're really just
all friends at the end,
it appears to be political subterfuge.
And President Trump
ostensibly backs this up
by tweeting in the alternative
that he hasn't interfered,
but that he has the right to do so,
which is worrying, he tweets,
"The President has never
asked me to do anything
"in a criminal case."
This doesn't mean that I
do not have, as president,
the legal right to do so, I do,
but I have so far chosen not to.
Of course, none of this
is happening in a vacuum.
All of these shenanigans are
going on less than a week
after Trump was acquitted by the Senate
on impeachment charges.
In that short time, the administration
has dismissed former
National Security Adviser,
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Vindman
and former US ambassador
to the European Union,
Gordon Sondland, both of whom testified
before the House Intelligence Committee's
impeachment hearings.
At the same time, Jessie
Liu, the ex-US attorney
that oversaw the original Roger Stone case
has resigned from the Trump administration
after the Trump administration
removed her nomination
for a top job at the Treasury Department.
And if we're looking for
historical precedent,
there's one that jumps out.
This whole situation is reminiscent
of the infamous Saturday Night Massacre
when then President, Nixon,
ordered his attorney general
and deputy attorney general
to fire a special prosecutor Archibald Cox
during the whole Watergate scandal.
They resigned and the
reluctant Solicitor General,
Robert Bork ultimately
handled Nixon's request.
Is Bill Barr Trump's Robert Bork?
Some would say yes.
But AG Barr seems anything but reluctant
to comply with Trump's demands.
Here on this channel, we
try to have fun with the law
and the news and we also
try to be fair and balanced
about the events as they unfold.
But I can't really
sugarcoat the situation.
Things are very bad here in Washington.
Even people who have worked with Barr
are sounding the alarm.
Former deputy AG Donald Ayer
served in the administration
of George H.W. Bush
and has known Barr for
over 40 years and said...
- I don't think he's fit for the office
because I think what he's done
is to undertake a campaign,
essentially to undermine
the Department of Justice.
- As at the time of this filming,
over 2000 former DOJ lawyers have called
on Barr to step down.
Of course, he's not going to
but condemnation from
career justice employee
shows the severity of this crisis.
The former employees wrote that, quote,
a person should not be
given special treatment
in criminal prosecution,
because they are a close
political ally of the President.
Governments that use the
enormous power of law enforcement
to punish their enemies
and reward their allies
are not constitutional republics.
They are autocracies.
And it's not just former
DOJ lawyers, either.
It's the judges as well.
A national association of federal judges,
which includes over 1000 federal judges,
and there aren't that many federal judges
has called an emergency meeting
to discuss political interference
in criminal prosecutions.
This isn't normal.
Okay, quick update, the news never sleeps
and I am coming to you
from VidCon, London.
I was going to release this video today,
but Roger Stone was sentenced.
So we know the outcome
to what happened here.
In this particular sentencing hearing,
the judge excoriated the DOJ.
She just went after them
for basically engaging
in political misconduct.
She confirmed that the DOJ originally
had the US Attorney for the district of DC
to confirm the sentence.
They talked to main justice,
and it was approved.
And John Crabb, the
acting US Attorney here
confirmed that there was some
sort of misunderstanding,
though he wouldn't explain
what that misunderstanding was.
After the judge excoriated the DOJ,
the judge engaged in her own calculation,
which a federal judge is want to do.
She accepted some of the
enhancements and rejected others.
She deviated slightly from the guidelines
and the judges are not bound
by the Federal Sentencing Guidelines
and the kind of deviation
that she engaged in
is totally normal.
So the end of the story
is that Roger Stone
got three years and four months in jail,
40 months in jail, and
he will serve that time
unless he is pardoned.
So back to Devon of the past to explain
the repercussions of this
particular hearing and sentencing.
So here's what we know
for certain, Roger Stone
is going to jail, probably.
But for the man who bragged
about his Stone's rules
and that it, quote, is
better to be infamous
than never to be famous at all.
Well, mission accomplished, sir.
And second, he's going to be
wearing an orange jumpsuit
for the foreseeable future.
Though it's possible he might
get a presidential pardon.
And while Stone suit
game is usually on point,
I doubt any of those penguinesque suits
are going to fit when he finally
gets out of federal prison.
So Roger when you get out of prison
and need to replace all your old suits,
I can't recommend Indochino highly enough,
especially if you want a
custom built slimcut suit,
your suits are looking a little bit baggy.
All of my suits are now made by Indochino,
including this awesome
brown checked three piece
that I'm wearing right now
because when you're
talking about Roger Stone,
you have to bring your A-game.
See the secret to a great
suit is all about the fit
and I'm a reasonably athletic guy
and I can never buy suits off the rack
because they simply never fit right.
And plus, they're crazy expensive.
If the shoulders fit,
the waist is too small,
it either doesn't fit right,
or it costs an arm and a leg
to get a tailor to fix it.
But with Indochino, you can
send in your measurements online
using the link in the description
or you can go to one of
their hundreds of stores
across the country and have a stylist
take your measurements personally.
For myself, I made an appointment.
I went to the store in person
and a stylist worked with me
for over 90 minutes when I
went in for the first time.
My personal stylist took my measurements
and a couple of weeks later,
I got the best fitting
suit of my entire life.
And the best part is I can
just reorder and reorder using
those exact measurements and
know that I'm going to get
a great suit every single time.
They're perfect right out of the box.
Indochino will make
you a fully custom suit
tailored specifically for
you for less than $400.
And the best part is they
still use the best materials
like super 140s wool.
In fact, LegalEagles can get
any premium Indochino suit
for just $359 if you use
the link in the description.
You can customize it exactly how you want
and get it made specifically
for your individual body
and nobody else.
I will never get an
off the rack suit again
and once you try it and neither will you.
LegalEagles can get any
premium Indochino suit
for just $359 when you use
the promo code LegalEagle
at checkout, or use the
link in the description,
so use the link below to
get the best custom suit
of your entire life.
Do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments.
And check out this playlist over here
for all of my other real law reviews
where I talk about all of the legal issues
that are in the news.
So click on this link and
I'll see you in court.